so we've had winner winner winner now
Timothy you didn't you didn't win you
didn't win but if it was is a
competition I'm talking about your
effort to do well in was it an exam
abouts it's all good right yes this is
true
III got a D in that yeah you got a Dee
got a D but but but I mean I I deserve
that or worse but so you're in school
you're doing an exam and statistics your
teacher she's miss Leighton yes Robin
Lawton lot miss Lawton and so what were
the other kids do with the other kids
just doing ya variation I mean I mean
some people presented parabolas and
things that were more appropriate for
statistics
you know varied projects my mind was not
so tell the people what you decided to
do like a statistics song yes sort of
sort of statistics ramp yeah
horrible bad bad worse lovely yeah but
no but you came up with a whole rap
persona didn't ya but not for that I
just had it oh so little is it little
Timmy Tim yeah it's per month
[Music]
but how do we have this film did you
post it how does this film except I
posted it I did it with a friend on a
green screen in school and I'm pointing
to different I was gonna photoshop my
teachers face in but I got too lazy so
now they're just kind of weird the video
I'm pointing around and there's well
here are the statistical rap stylings of
lil Timmy tee
it's Timmy tee
see the probability you see me on TV
[Applause]
[Music]
you